unbiased news is a myth ground news is a
news comparison platform that empowers
you to see how the political biases of
different sources are influencing the
news you read
download the ground news app for free at
davidpakman.comground
joe biden promised to deliver 100
million vaccine doses
into the arms of americans in a hundred
days and
we are i am thrilled to say on track to
dramatically surpass
that and at the same time we are seeing
coronavirus cases continue to decline
uh very quickly faster than than many
people expected so let's
run through the numbers then i have
other covet updates we did this
each of the last few weeks i didn't
think that many people would would
actually
like this but it turns out a lot of
people aren't following the day-to-day
of what's going on with the virus
understandably and a ton of people wrote
in saying
actually the summaries are useful in
terms of where we are so let's jump
right in with one disclaimer
i'm going to give a lot of optimistic
news in this segment
it should not be used to encourage us
to stop being careful the optimistic
news should tell us let's keep
being careful not go crazy and if we do
that then there is hopefully a light at
the end of the tunnel
and yes i will address the variance of
course all right so let's start with
cases coronavirus
cases on average peaked on january 11th
at about 255 000 cases per day an insane
number
the good news is that since that peak
cases have declined
a whopping 64 where we are now
averaging 92 000 cases per day
now this is all perspective at one point
a year ago when dr
fauci said not a year ago eight months
ago seven months ago when dr fauji said
if we aren't careful we could
get up to a hundred thousand cases per
day in the fall and a whole bunch of
people said that's impossible
and of course dr fauci was right we
weren't careful and we actually got not
to 100 000 cases a day
not to 200 000 cases a day we actually
had 300 300 000 cases a day
we had 300 000 cases on one day uh in
the fall
we are now back down to 92 000 cases per
day but what matters is the rate of
decline
down 64 in just 35 days you love to see
it
let's keep it going now in the meantime
deaths
which lag cases by three to four weeks
are finally starting to come down
peaking at an average of about 3 500
deaths a day in the united states
more 20 more than a 911 a day
now down 25 percent to a daily average
of about
2600 deaths per day still
an unconscionable horrifying number
but we are seeing the improvement and
the improvement in deaths should track
the decline
in cases as well with about a three to
four week lag
now to vaccination joe biden promised
a million doses a day the u.s is now
exceeding that by a full two-thirds
with one and two-thirds million
vaccine doses per day going into
people's arms
with again new record days this weekend
2.2 million doses administered on
saturday 2.2 million doses
administered on sunday these are
fantastic numbers
but they are not enough because at the
current rates
we wouldn't hit 50 immunity until june
28th we wouldn't reach 70
immunity a key number until september
5th so as i've said before
i didn't come up with this medical
experts did the ideal would be to get to
3.5 million doses per day
that would dramatically accelerate our
progress it's not impossible that we
would get there with a third vaccine
and hopefully with a fourth vaccine now
let's talk about vaccines and variants
once again we continue to learn more and
more about this
we have two vaccines currently in use in
the united states the moderna vaccine
and the pfizer vaccine these are both
two dose vaccines
with moderna you have 28 days between
doses with pfizer you have 21 days
between doses okay we are close to
approval for
a third vaccine the johnson johnson
vaccine that is a one
dose vaccine that will dramatically
simplify logistics and
could get us could get us to 2.53
million vaccines a day regularly
fourth vaccine has the possibility of
getting us to three and a half million
vaccines a day
meanwhile what we know about the
effectiveness of these vaccines is
stunning it
it's not a miracle it's science so i
don't want to use the word miracle
but the numbers appear almost miraculous
israel
has done an incredible job with
vaccination they're already vaccinating
younger people
and uh the deal they made with pfizer is
that they will open up their data
so pfizer can get more information about
how the vaccine works in reality
one study of the vaccinated israeli
population
found that in the real world the vaccine
has 94 efficacy at preventing
symptomatic disease and a 92
drop in severe disease listen to these
numbers
a study of 525 000 vaccinated israelis
found
only 500 of them got the virus
that's 0.1
525 000 people 500 get the virus with
the vaccine
and that was including some of them got
it between doses they weren't yet
at full immunity of the 500 people
that got the virus four
of the 500 had what you would call a
serious case
four and none of them died
these are incredible incredible numbers
the vaccine appears to be as good
in real life as it was in the phase
three trials
now it's not all great news we are
in a fight against these variants that
are spreading
the good news in that fight is that the
moderna and pfizer vaccines
appear really effective against the uk
variant and the brazilian variant and
they appear less
but still quite effective against the
south
south africa variant it's just a matter
of speed
the faster we vaccinate the more we
prevent mutation the
more we prevent the spread of the
variants which
are slightly stronger
against the vaccine if you imagine the
variance in a fight against the vaccines
and the more
we can control this so if we can keep
this going
we are going to have a very different
situation statistically in the united
states by april 1st
and again a different situation by may
1st if we can get
beyond one and two-thirds million
vaccines a day if we can get to 2.5
steady or
3 we are looking at moving up the date
at which 70
of the country will be vaccinated from
early september
into august possibly even into july or
according to some models even late june
if we can really quickly
ramp up vaccinations so let's keep
tracking numbers
the milestone i'm next looking for is
when we get under
50 000 cases per day that might only be
weeks away
if we can keep going it could be longer
we will soon
see and fortunately vaccine hesitancy
i won't dive into that a lot now because
we did that last week
vaccine hesitancy also continues to go
down
all good things um we are hoping also
for approval on the vaccination of uh
kids um you know 10 12
14 years old by early summer
optimistically and that will also be a
big factor so
a lot of good things happening not the
time to go crazy
not the time to go crazy light at the
end of the tunnel we see it
okay let's talk about joe biden on
immigration now
joe biden has made it clear that the
immediate next priority is coveted
relief
i've already criticized and said it
should have been done already
it hasn't we're hoping that it gets done
soon very soon thereafter
immigration is going to be high on joe
biden's list now
much of what joe biden wants to do on
immigration cannot be done
by executive order one bit of good news
is that joe biden
has cancelled the national emergency
order that donald trump was using
to try to get money for
his border wall joe biden sent a letter
to congress late last week
saying that no further tax dollars will
be spent on the wall
now you might be wondering but there was
no wall
trump promised a wall across the entire
border it never happened what are we
talking about here
that is true but remember that donald
trump
declared a state of emergency over the
southern border in 2019
that allowed him to use some military
funding
for construction of the wall now the
disastrous news
is that trump did manage to spend 25
billion
on the project the unfortunate it's sort
of like a pyrrhic victory that donald
trump had because he was able to obtain
money for the wall
but they were really able to do mostly
some replacement of existing border wall
areas with a new type of wall
and expand it slightly so as far as a
campaign promise trump failed on having
a wall across the entire border
that was his promise he made it very
very clearly and said that was a first
term
accomplishment that he would have didn't
happen on the other hand
it's it's good news in the sense that
not much of it
took place and joe biden is able to shut
down
this emergency uh declaration of
emergency
and to stop pulling any more money from
the military for
the wall this is the continued use of
executive orders by joe biden
to undo many of the disasters that
donald trump did of course
much like debt and deficit executive
orders have become a political football
if your guy or gal is in power and using
executive orders
then you say these executive orders are
required and necessary to undo the
damage of the previous president
if your guy or gal is not
in the oval office then you call
executive orders at least if you're a
republican a
um sort of authoritarian tyrannical
circumvention of the normal legislative
process that's
that's the way it's been for a while
it's pretty similar to the
debt and deficit uh but it is a good
thing that joe biden has been doing this
particularly
when the republican party is more
obstructionist arguably than it has ever
been
um the exact numbers are that 80 miles
of new barriers were built
during the trump administration where
there were none and
otherwise there were just replacements
of existing parts of
border wall or border fencing so i think
this is an important time to just
remind you that we know a lot about what
circumstances call for a wall and what
circumstances do not
um one of the really interesting things
is that even without the wall
remember trump only added 80 miles
without a wall across the entire border
as promised by trump
trump regularly claimed border crossings
are lower than ever
so that's proof that it's if you believe
that
that's proof that it is not a wall that
reduces
border crossings and of course we've
long studied the reasons why it is
absurd to spend
these ungodly amounts of money on a wall
we know that
and we've seen examples of being able to
scale the wall
with about 100 in parts from any
hardware store home depot lows that type
of place
it is easily defeated number two uh you
have a significant portion of people who
are in the united states
illegally who have overstayed visas or
came
for uh tourism and never left and they
are mostly
flying in not crossing the physical
border
at the u.s mexico border and then lastly
if you want to think about the best roi
the best return on investment
for dealing with the issue of
undocumented immigration
we really should be approaching this
from why are people
wanting to come to the united states to
begin with
understanding the economic conditions in
the source countries not just mexico but
further south as well
and working with those countries and if
we are supposed to be
sort of agnostic to how the money is
spent as long as it effectively deals
with the undocumented immigration
problem
then you would think that the right
would be open to the ideas of economists
and
others who have said well let's instead
of building a wall
that can be defeated and won't actually
address a lot of the people that fly in
and overstay visas or just never leave
when they come for for vacation
let's actually spend money by improving
economic circumstances in some of these
source countries now the the problem is
we know that for them a big aspect of
this is not just doing what's most
effective it's what doing what feels
right
based on their uh framework of morality
as they would call it or or maybe as we
would describe it
and to them it would seem wrong
in some way to give money to improve
a country when people are coming here
illegally it just doesn't
feel right to the ideology that many of
these right-wingers are committed to but
study after study as we've outlined in
our long-form piece about this issue
confirms that that actually would be the
most effective way to curb
undocumented immigration to the united
states so the micro story
joe biden has cut that emergency
declaration there is not even a
mechanism
with which you could pull money from the
military to build the wall
next step is biden's got to deal with
daca and it is finally time with
democrats controlling the white house
the house
and the senate if it's not going to
happen now i don't know that it will
ever happen
it's finally time to really do the
immigration reform we've been talking
about for i mean it's been 15 years or
longer at this point
send me your thoughts you can find me on
twitter at d pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the riots at the capitol made it very
clear that misinformation
is one of the biggest problems that our
society faces and online filter bubbles
make the problem worse
making it difficult even for intelligent
news consumers to figure out what's true
and what's not
one of our sponsors is ground news which
is a platform with a really effective
approach
to combating this problem ground news is
the world's first news comparison
platform that lets you compare
how sources from across the political
spectrum are covering a story
i use it myself i love it because it
lets me
easily see how different news outlets
are manipulating a story to fit their
own narrative
and it shows you your news blind spots
stories that your side of the political
spectrum
may not be giving attention to start out
2021
with a balanced news diet download the
ground news app for free
by going to davidpakman.com ground
the link is right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show as a show depends
on people who like what we are doing
enough
to grab a membership at jointpakman.com
we also do a daily
bonus show an extra show every single
day
just for our members i implore you
to grab a membership at joinpacman.com
and you can use the coupon code better21
if you would like
to save some money off of the cost of a
membership
we have a very interesting new poll
out of quinnipiac university about
whether
republicans want donald trump to remain
involved in american politics and in
republican party politics for the
foreseeable future and the answer
is yes they do yes they do
three-quarters of republicans
want donald trump to continue playing a
prominent role
in the republican party the poll showed
89
of republicans opposed the conviction of
donald trump
in his senate second senate impeachment
trial
87 percent of republicans say trump
should be allowed to hold public office
in the future
89 percent of republicans believe trump
was not responsible for inciting the
violence that led to the january 6th
riots and among all americans polled
55 percent oppose trump
republing uh returning to public office
so this is a very
important um number
because we talked last week or the week
before
about 64 of republicans saying
if trump left the party uh
and started his own party we would
follow him
nearly two-thirds of the republican
party has such
soft support for the party or has simply
accepted donald trump as the sort of
lord and savior
deity head of the party at this point
that they would follow him
out of it that's not so good for the
republican party
as an institution but it's certainly
good if you're donald trump and you want
to control
the republican party or american
politics going forward
now we learn that although there are
some republicans who would not leave the
republican party to follow trump
many of them do want trump to continue
involved in american politics now one
important caveat is that we know from
our conversation with david shore
a few weeks ago that republicans
who answer the phone and talk to
pollsters
are not necessarily representative of
all republicans and and david shore
believes that
some of the more trumpy and q anon
conspiracy types may be refusing to
participate in polls of course pollsters
try to and believe they have ways of
accounting and adjusting for that but
david shore was
skeptical that they really are great at
it so that's something
something to understand but assuming
these numbers are roughly accurate
this is really bad for republicans as a
party they lost the presidential
election by almost 8 million people
and at this point in time
most of them want trump to stay involved
and two-thirds are even willing
to leave the party i don't know how the
math
works out for them and what i mean by
that is if you lose a national election
by 8 million
in great part because of the guy who's
at the head of the party donald trump
failing on coronavirus turning off so
many traditional republicans you lose by
8 million
and then you want that guy to stay
involved and if he leaves the party
you'll leave with him
those are not numbers that bode well for
the republican party in national
elections now at the local level it's a
very different situation
you can still you know the trumpian
factor
in extremely red areas that would
never consider voting for for example a
democratic senator it may in practice
not have that big of an
impact but for as long as donald trump
is so prominent it looks really tough
for the republican party to win national
elections and i'm glad to have my mind
changed but i don't see how the numbers
work out
now as a matter of sort of following the
nature
the easy nature by which so many
republican voters were bamboozled by
donald trump
they fell for the populist sounding
rhetoric back in 2015 and 2016. we've
talked about that many times yeah they
fell for it and then trump didn't do it
but they still don't seem to realize
that trump has done
nothing for just your average working
class
republican beyond yes making them really
afraid of others that are going to do
bad things to you
china undocumented immigrants democrats
communists marxists
anarchists or anarchists as donald trump
would call them
yeah he stoked fears for the average
working-class republican really well
he told them lies about the things he
would do said he would fix trade he
didn't do it
said he would build a wall across the
entire u.s mexico border he didn't do it
said he would replace obamacare with a
beautiful new health care plan didn't do
it
so fear false promises
coalescing the most hateful elements of
the republican party
but they still seem not to realize that
he did nothing for them economically
the way he claimed to do and now as we
know 40
of coronavirus deaths during the trump
administration
were unnecessary and avoidable so
of course all of the numbers wow how
does the republican party
win national elections in these
circumstances but the the other question
is
millions tens of millions still don't
realize trump didn't do any of the
things he said he would do for the
working class do they care do they not
no i'm not sure
i don't know the answer but if they
never wake up to it
support for trump in the republican
party is likely to continue
this is really funny just because of the
the hypocrisy in it
there's a guy who donated uh more than
two million dollars
to that completely bogus true the vote
campaign to try to
take the election back from joe biden
despite the fact that joe biden won
and now one of these guys uh wants his
money back
and says he's essentially been scammed
i'm talking about
right-wing rich dude fred eshelman
fred eshelman was convinced after the
presidential election that something
wasn't right with the results
and so he decided to donate a bunch of
money
to true the vote he uh called
the group and said i'm in for two
million dollars
and over the next a couple weeks that
followed
eshelman came to regret the donation
realized that all of these uh conspiracy
theories
about rampant illegal voting deserved to
be doubted
yes yes they did and now he wants his
money back
and uh trump's campaign and the
republican party
in total collected more than a quarter
billion dollars that's 255 million
dollars in two months
they said the money would go to legal
challenges they said the money would go
to recounts and so on and so forth
very little of the money did 76 million
that trump raised
for georgia and for uh reversing the
results of the election
didn't go to that instead it went to
paying off donald trump's campaign debts
and now at least some of these
individuals
are saying we got scammed and we want
our money back
now eshelman has filed two lawsuits
and one uh one in federal court has
since been withdrawn
the other is still going on in texas
state court
and he is alleging they didn't spend the
money on the things they were going to
spend the money on
and i want the money back and um
at this point you know there's a couple
different things that i think are
relevant to talk about here
first of all um with these types of
things
one should never invest more than they
are willing to lose i mean it's not
different than cryptocurrency in a sense
i've talked about i've held bitcoin
for for years at this point and i
consider it
speculative i consider it part of a
small
portion of my assets that i am putting
in what i know to be risky assets and if
it ends up being worth zero if i get
nothing from it that's sort of part of
the game
anybody who quote invested and i think
that that's
absolutely the wrong term who invested
money
in this truth the vote campaign you
should have gone in knowing this may go
to nothing i am not going in assuming or
expecting that there are going to be
tangible results here clearly fred
eshelman didn't do that because he was
bamboozled by the conspiracy theory so
he was played by trump and many of these
people were played by trump now in terms
of whether they deserve to get their
money back
if you actually believed
that this was anything short of a grift
then you clearly were not paying
attention
and i i do believe that some people like
fred eshelman
may not necessarily have thought that it
was a scam
but they certainly might have felt that
i'm a rich dude if i throw enough money
at a problem
something good is going to happen
because that's how a lot of these rich
people
operate in the united states it's just a
matter of throwing enough money at it
and i can get whatever i want okay maybe
some of these claims are exaggerated but
if i give two million bucks two and a
half million people
cough up 250 million dollars if you
throw enough money at a problem we're
gonna get the outcome that we want
because that's how
a lot of these folks now have been
conditioned uh
but in terms of getting the money back
a lot of these same people now alleging
a scam and saying i'm filing sued and
they're the ones who say we can't have a
nanny state government we can't have a
nanny state government protecting people
from themselves if people want to smoke
they should be allowed to smoke if
people want 128 ounce sodas
they should be allowed to have them and
it shouldn't be priced a different way
or banned or whatever the case may be
and now they're saying something
different shouldn't by that same very
same logic
they be allowed to donate money wherever
they want
and then the outcome is the outcome
caveat emptor buyer beware
no now they have a different approach
and i don't know ultimately what's going
to happen in court but it is amazing
that you know there
there might be this idea that the only
people trump was able to bamboozle
were lower middle class uneducated
rural folks no no no that's very wrong
trump also
bamboozled uh rich uh upper class folks
and uh we should never understate
the ability of a grifter to grift lots
of different people
we'll have more coverage of this on the
show's instagram page you can find us on
instagram at david pakman show
we have a lot coming up today including
some really almost sad
segments on fox news last night which
we'll get to a little bit later today
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership
is not just a feel-good thing you get
access to the world-famous bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join p
a pakman.com if the normal prices strike
you is high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
today we're going to be speaking to
economist
ariel rubinstein professor of economics
at tel aviv university
and at new york university thank you so
much for your time i appreciate speaking
with you
my pleasure so one of the two really two
areas that are very much uh in right now
in economics are game theory and
behavioral economics
and if one reads critiques of these
areas
one of the things i read frequently is
that as
interesting as game theory and
behavioral economics are
to study uh theoretically that
there is a limit to what these fields of
study can tell us about
the real world do you believe that this
is a fair
criticism uh
it's a very fair criticism and i would
sign on everywhere that you have said
let me first of all say you know every
area and probably in the sciences
and also as in life as inflation and in
other things
in politics then we have waves
and the waves are not because somebody
discovered the light or discovered some
the the corona cured the corona the wave
is because some sort of social pressures
inside the academic world
so when i was very young then what was
called general equilibrium was
dominating economics
then actually i was a part of what is
called the game theoretical revolution
in economics and that became
so fashionable that actually young phds
now
almost don't know general equilibrium
and
and the next wave was behavioral
economics and the next wave
is probably something which is very far
from
from theoretical developments but any
case this is first of all the fact that
something is dominating
a field inside economics does not mean
that this is true
it is really me it does mean that it's
dominating it's also it should be
it should be said that economics is
probably again
is any other political group is very
much
there is there is a little bit a tyranny
of the governing
of the dominating field and when some
field is on top
then it's quite rejects the other fields
my position about economic economic
theory in general
that it's not about truth it's not about
tools nothing is true it's a little bit
like literature
you know sometimes there is a facial is
one type of literature is more
fashionable
another time another type of little
chair is very fashionable my attitude in
general
to generally to economic theory that
this is a bunch of stories
about if you want a bunch of fables
now these failures are not completely
disconnected from the world
they are connected with them well but
remind you that also disney fables are
connected to the world
so it's connected to the well it's about
the wealth in some sense but
not in the direct way that people think
or many people take it and
now regarding uh continuing in this line
when we think about game theory you know
i spent much of my life
doing game theory and i don't do game
theory anymore i should say
i moved from gabriel to bandung
nationality and then these days i'm
doing things which are more connected to
general equilibrium than to the game
theory
and and that's not because there was
this
i was dissoluted from game theory i've
never
believed i've never understood that game
theory is
some concrete lesson to
or message to the world and whenever
people
and some of them are very respectable
people that i admire
on their academic achievements try to
claim that gamesview will tell something
about
politics about life about religion or
whatever
i feel very angry i should say
do you think though that over time we
will get closer
to economic theory that really does tell
us more or is
is more highly applicable in the real
world and i guess the
the idea would be we had this initial
school of economics that was based on
perfectly rational actors and then over
time we learned
okay that's not exactly the way things
work let's introduce behavioral
economics which at least
claimed to get closer to accounting for
the psychology of the real world and
maybe gets us a little closer
do you think over time we will get
closer and closer
no you don't no no no not in the means
that categorically not in the means that
we work on now of course it may be the
case
that in one point of time i
in some sense i hope that it's after i
will i will go from this world
that the wealth will be so different
that there will be some that is that we
will
um there with the way to model david or
ariel
would not be in the way the formal way
or the abstract way that we do it but it
will be
we will be people think we think about
us indeed as machines
really machines as the sort of
collection of of
atoms or a collection of cells that some
interact in some
way and people will some will understand
and decode it and then
we will stop to be dividend area will be
some sort of organisms in the world and
then the world will be
so much different than the world that we
live in
that you know the question whether
economic theory will do the work or not
is completely unimportant
uh it will be completely i cannot
imagine such a world
now i cannot say that it's impossible
you know who i am i'm not a scientist
i'm an
early economist so i am to say that
that's impossible one day
but i i personally i in in a
continuing mode is developing the
theories even making
making them more empirically in some
sense
relevant uh i don't think that we are as
close because
and again the analogy is the analogy of
literature
do you believe that one day there will
be a book that in some sense will
explain
the world in the perfect way that
whoever will read it we say
wow now i understand the politics of the
u.s and i predict
the elections in in 2024
i maybe i i cannot
i cannot imagine something you you
mentioned bounded rationality and i want
to talk about that a little bit
maybe for the people in our audience who
are less familiar with some of these
concepts
in general when we talk about
rationality
in economics what do we mean and then
what do you mean
when we talk about more specifically
bounded rationality
well the way that i'm in bounded
nationality i mean i
that in the story namely what we call a
model in our language but it's i think
about it's just a story
there is a concrete element of the
procedural aspect of decision making
that's all
when we talk about russian models with
rationality
actually we also have a sort of a
procedure but the procedure is in some
sense
perfect in some logical sense people can
do and whatever calculations
they fully understand the probabilistic
laws
etc etc on the other hand when people
are limited and all of us are limited
and we take it into account or we put it
we don't take into account we know it i
think about it more that we put it
explicitly
into the model that there are some
aspects of boundary rationalities and
it's become a model of bonus
that's all that's all but of course in
the interpretation of what we do this is
a big step it's a big
step because it's uh it makes some of
the results so many of the results that
are
coming in the model when we assume full
rationality
uh different that's all
would it be fair to say that would it be
fair to say that rationality as a broad
concept
is a more theoretical concept bounded
rationality accounts for the real world
limits of rationality i don't know i
you know if you take you know the the
the example that i
often give is the again the characters
in disney in disney movies
yeah characters these and movies are
usually are very simple
in the sense that either they are good
or bad right
it's either they're evil or sadic
that's uh these are two
extremes and now we can think about the
way that people are either they have
some sort of a click in their minds a
zero one either
that's the end of the story and then
still our interaction between many good
and bad
people in different situations now we
can complicate it and think about the
situation is more
more evolved and more include some sort
of
between between being good and bad how
many colors and between being fully
rational
and being completely random there is
also a lot of
varieties and when we are interested in
the way
or that this procedural aspect affect
the the interaction between human beings
then it becomes a bound nationality
now if it's closer i don't like to think
about it
closer i think that it's different and
again
closer under behind your assumption
there is
there is this goal which is that
economic theory
will be uh will predict the world will
be
will fit the description of the well as
close as possible i
personally i must say i've never wanted
to predict anything
i don't want to predict i i i i
i want to i want to to do interesting
story
to write to invent interesting stories
full stop what the interesting stories
we do to the world
well you know there are some interesting
stories that were written by people
much more
famous than me that really changed the
world
and and and and i don't think that the
type of models that we
deal with will change the world they the
most they affect the way
that economies or politio people are
doing social sciences
or think about social sciences or person
like you
would think about about the world but
this is in a very indirect way the
influence is exactly in my opinion
almost exactly like literature probably
the difference is that
there is that there is i don't think
that when people read
a novel they they they have expectations
that everything will be
correct exactly describe the world and
so on but the other and also the
influence
of lee of course there are some writers
who were becoming prime ministers and
presidents and so on
but most of the writers do not do
whatever they do
in in direct relation to politicians or
to people who do
public affairs the difference between a
disrespect between
writers and in the economy is that there
is i think that most of the people
including many of my friends economists
and definitely people think about
economics and people who write in
the words the journal and the economic
section in newspapers and so on
approach economies with expectations
that they will
tell them things which are very very
useful
now uh you know you know some people
believe that
economics of course is much more useful
in the direct
sense than me and i you know i think
that the
burden of proof is on them not on me um
i it's not my goal i never gave i've
never given any advice to anybody
and i'm not going to give you guys
that's fair so so putting aside for a
moment the idea of
predictive utility can you talk
maybe about some examples of situations
that we can maybe better
understand by understanding bounded
rationality what types of real world
real
world problems might we better
understand under this umbrella
uh to be honest it's a very you ask me
now a very tough question
i i don't think that i can it would be a
challenge
move for me now to in a few minutes to
to say okay here is an example such and
such
when i was doing more game theory and i
was asked many times the same questions
so probably i was i fell into the trap
and answer this question
with some examples and when i ended the
interview or whatever
and i said oh come on again i did this
mistake
and nobody understood and there and the
and what i meant and
look the economic show in many respects
it's uh it's um it's
a it's a study of the way that
economists
think and it's very difficult and
sometimes it's very
dangerous to transfer the terms directly
in public by the way that's the success
you mentioned the behavioral economics
the big success
the public success of behavioral
economics is because the other
economists
have a very direct communication
with the public why they are very
directly
because actually many of the examples
and the stories that they can tell are
very simple
and actually makes a lot of sense and
many of them are not very
great academic achievements but it is
just common sense
and and therefore you know you can give
a speech about
behavioral economics and people will be
very excited because they will feel that
actually they understand the lecture and
actually they feel probably that they
themselves knew some of the stuff that
is told
and so on i mean is that is that a
that's an important bias maybe to
understand right the idea that
that which can be more easily understood
people may be more likely to believe it
is accurate
but that may not be the case it's it's
not not only
you see behavioral economics one of the
big effects in the last
few years is what is called the let's me
call it the nudge movement
the nudge movement is almost the
political movements these days
it says those of the listeners that they
don't know what it is it is a
some very respectable economist and
not only economists in other fields
believe
that what is called libertarian
paternalism namely we don't want to
force people
to to take the vaccination let's say
that's an issue now in israel
but we don't want to force them and
we're illegal to force them but we can
nudge them to to to do it and
they study some ways that we imagine
more effectively now behind this api
this of course
is the the the there is a lot of
debates in the last few years about the
philosophical
personally i'm very much against this
movement because of many reasons
uh one of them that i believe that
people now it's not that's
not connected with economics it's just
in my personal views
i believe in the the personal
responsibility to a person and i also
believe
that clever people who people or
economists or scholars who believe that
are very clever
don't know what is good to other people
more than the people themselves and i
feel
that manipulation on people i dismay a
lot
that people even with the best intention
manipulate other people to do something
i feel that it's for me it is operation
which is immoral
in almost almost all uh operations so in
a sense in a sense
the questions about libertarian
paternalism
actually are things that there's very
little to do with
with academic research these are ideas
that we can discuss
in in in the in a bar or in the
afternoon
or in the evening dinner or over the
table and
discuss them and and probably you will
have some insights as a person who is
connected with
human beings not less than many of the
scholars of of of behavioral economics
so i think that again it's not said
beyond economics there's not
any interesting stories it has but
the but the the potential of behavioral
economics to be
more realistic and more and especially
the
the the the the move the which is almost
a political move
that you are trying to claim we know
how to do something and we actually are
behind the scenes actually manipulate
other people in the name of
academic ideas i i've personally
dismayed from any angle that i can think
about
we've been speaking with ariel
rubinstein who is professor of economics
at tel aviv university
and at new york university a professor
such a pleasure speaking with you today
i appreciate your time my pleasure
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media
and you can contribute any amount you
want on patreon
as little as one dollar per month plus
you can get the daily
bonus show world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
david pakman show
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so you really have to see this uh donald
trump jr
is so desperate for time on air
but also desperate for opportunities to
talk about how his
beloved father the former president is
just
so liked by everyone that he went on
sean hannity's fox news program last
night
on which there were multiple segments
about
a group of people that came out in
florida with trump flags to cheer donald
trump on president's day
as donald trump drove i guess from
golfing back to his
resort or something like that and this
as i was watching this
i actually almost felt slightly sorry
for don jr who of course
is just so desperate to be liked by his
dad
but so desperate to try to keep the
party going for lack of a better term
check this out first you're going to see
a clip here of sean hannity claiming
that this group of several
it appears to be several hundred trump
supporters spontaneously appeared
to cheer on trump as he returned from
golfing now if you watch the video
you're gonna notice people with gigantic
flags like eight foot ten foot flags
these are not things you can say oh
trump's gonna drive through
i'll just pop into 7-eleven and get a
10-foot
don't tread on me or magga or
maga or trump flag you have to plan for
this stuff
the police cordons clearly were
organized ahead of time anyway nothing
about it seems spontaneous
but here's hannity saying look at this
spontaneous thing that just
popped up this very day take a look
right there
see that video see what's on your screen
a few hours ago
spontaneously thousands of people
in palm beach lined up in support of the
former president
as his motorcade traveled through
florida
um i have a question mitch mcconnell
john thune
how come you never had this kind of
enthusiasm at
any of your events take a look a defiant
sean hannity there
saying hey listen a senator like john
thune barely known to anybody
never had people with flags
cheering them like a former president of
the united states what a kind of strange
flex that is
but anyway then that's not all because
in comes don jr to talk about the quote
totally organic parade of flag bearing
trumpists that appeared
uh take a look at this you're looking at
dad coming back from golf did you see
thousands of people out of nowhere
nobody
nobody organized it that i could see
necessarily nobody associated with your
father that i know of
do you uh no
i mean this is totally organic and again
it just shows that
the american people are with donald
trump uh those millions of people sean i
saw it all day i put up a separate video
even to the one that you posted earlier
now that's it's actually really funny
how hannity
hedges nobody organized thousands of
people
and a police presence well no one
associated with your father anyway and i
guess what
sean hannity means is that trump didn't
organize it himself
okay and don jr really
seems to be struggling with the math
there and you can't you kept hearing
this during the impeachment trial
actually the disenfranchisement
of 74 million people who voted for trump
a few hundred
or even a thousand people getting out to
support someone
in a country of 330 million people
when joe biden got millions more votes
than donald trump
what mathematical significance do a few
hundred or even a thousand people have
now on the facts they're of course lying
to you
there was nothing organic or spontaneous
about this event it was president's day
yesterday
people came from relatively far away
from the for this
they drove with their flags and
people knew about the event starting at
least a week before it was being
promoted there was nothing coincidental
about it here's one advertisement for
the event
from right side broadcasting network
starting to promote this well in advance
they even say bring your flags
those flags you can't just stop in a
7-eleven or a walmart
and get an 8-foot trump flag you've got
to plan ahead and what's more sad
i mean listen there's there's a lot of
sad stuff going on here
one thing is like they always have to go
further they could just go with
there was great turnout on president's
day for donald trump
okay all right well a few hundred
supporters came out that's great
why do you have to say it was
spontaneous and it just popped up out of
nowhere like it's completely
unbelievable obviously it didn't pop out
of nowhere
but maybe what's more sad is that
donald trump jr is desperate not just
for relevance but he's so desperate for
dad's approval
and that is it you know we this is a
cycle
that repeats itself we don't have to get
all psychological but
donald trump was desperate for his dad's
approval
and his dad treated him terribly and
that's where a lot of trump's complex
comes from
and it seems to be repeated exactly
between donald trump and donald trump jr
it's all sad quite frankly uh but it is
what it is as they say and
uh hopefully this will at some point
kind of wind down
hey so listen this is not the most
important story
but we all need a little comedic relief
every once in a while and last night on
tucker carlson's fox news show
guest after guest lost their connection
and i don't know why
but i just found it hilarious i think
part of it is the look on tucker
carlson's face every time his guests
would lose connection now
i want to be really really clear texas
is having power outages right now
one of the guests who loses their
internet connection
is former republican governor rick perry
and tucker carlson mentions him being in
texas now i don't know if the storms are
actually the reason rick perry loses
internet
and all of his guests even the ones not
in texas were losing connection
so it may have nothing to do but we are
not
making light of what is happening in
texas right now people without power
okay that's not what this is about
i think what's funny is tucker doing his
confused face every time it happens so
if you're only listening that will be an
element that you won't be able to
observe unless you take a look at the
video versions of this but let's jump
right into it
here is former texas governor former
trump
administration secretary of energy rick
perry
losing his connection and tucker tries
to at least
blame it on rick's connection although i
doubt whether that's what's going on
let's take a look
so i i love texas
don't want to attack texas on the other
hand the most basic responsibility of
government you'd think is to keep the
power on especially when people needed
to survive they didn't why
hmm
i should say that rick perry is in texas
it sounded like he was in space but he's
not he's in texas he has no power
that's being run i think on a generator
he's proving the point that we're making
governor we're going to put you on hold
for a second to see if we can get the
power back on in your state
okay so maybe it's the storms there but
then
in comes florida governor ron desantis
a republican governor who was going on
tucker's show
to brag about how they're just opening
it wide open
in florida uh regardless of the virus
and
he loses his connection now at this
point you can't blame the power outages
in texas
for ron desantis losing his connection
can you take a look
ever says that out loud i mean how could
you ignore something
that the data show
oh i'm afraid we've lost governor
desantis
can you hear me governor i can't hear
oh i'm sorry about that i can hear the
governor he cannot hear me i just want
to say for the record that unlike as in
texas tonight
i think the power is still on in florida
fewer windmills
in the state than there are in texas so
that's the good news but for some reason
the governor couldn't hear us we'll be
back in
just a moment a lot going on i i was
having a grand old time
re-watching these this morning it's also
very
poetic that a connection was lost
because these are two people rick perry
and ron desantis
who lost their connections with reality
a long time ago and i would actually
argue that this was ron desantis's
best public statement ever just losing
his connection and
being unable to say anything he came off
looking way better than he normally does
when he's able to speak and notice
tucker carlson
throwing in a dig at wind farms there
sort of laughing at windmills and i
think the idea there
is that tucker wants to frame anybody
relying on wind farms can't possibly be
keeping the power
on compared to burning fossil fuels
which i guess is seen as
manly and alpha among the american right
no opportunity to attack clean energy
that tucker carlson won't
avail himself of and i mean listen being
texas i'd almost expect tucker to blame
the power outages or the loss of
connection
on some migrant caravan approaching the
border which seems to be a catch-all
anytime they need to
blame anybody for anything maybe even
antifa but
uh many tech problems happening on
tucker carlson's program last night i
don't know why
i was laughing to myself this morning
just really really got a kick out of
that one
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p uh we got a voicemail late
last week about this new march 4th thing
there are q and on people who
i don't even know that i can say they
believe it they are saying maybe they
believe it
q anon people are now saying that
through some kind of
bizarre technicality donald trump is
going to
resume his presidency on march 4th
and i said isn't this in some sense
mental illness
delusional in a way and a caller left me
a voicemail saying it is but there's
also some of that on the left let's take
a listen
the latest march 4th q and on thing
let's call it what it is
it's mental illness okay but the
democrats are also
guilty of having mental illness they
think this
is the wizard of oz where at some point
the republicans are going to discover
that they had a brain the whole time
they had courage the whole time they had
conscience the whole time
they just didn't know it right it was
there all along
well guess what alice that's never going
to happen
because they don't have courage they
don't have conscience
and they don't have a brain and this
march 4th
babel is mental illness and i would
propose
that to give it any media attention at
all
even on admittedly an anti-q and on
youtube progressive channel still
gives it a voice that it doesn't deserve
all right so there is a big admonishment
there but no i think that
the the what i what i completely agree
with is
you know throughout the trump president
for law for decades honestly it happened
during george w
bush it kept happening but certainly
during the trump presidency
there would be the sense where oh
this is too much even the trumpian
lunatics aren't going to defend this
clearly republican senators are now
going to say this
is too far and of course it never
happened and
it is in a sense insanity to keep
repeating the same expectation
absent any evidence that should make us
think this is too far this
is too low even for republicans to think
no it never is
it never is and i do think that that's
an important
uh important takeaway and uh the caller
is absolutely right
on the bonus show today house
impeachment managers
are defending their decision not to call
witnesses in the trump impeachment trial
after they voted to call witnesses
that's one story number two
joe biden is launching a review of the
guantanamo bay detention center
and he is planning to close it before
leaving office
we're still doing this yes we're still
talking about closing gitmo
maybe joe biden can get it done and
parlor
is back again it's like the website that
just won't die parlor is back again
we'll talk a little bit about the latest
iteration and uh what uh
impact it's having on the conservative
dialogue i guess we would call it
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get
instant access by becoming a member at
joinpakman.com i'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
unbiased news is a myth ground news is a
news comparison platform that empowers
you to see how the political biases of
different sources are
influencing the news you read download
the ground news app for free
at davidpakman.com ground